[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum if you're hearing my
voice for the first time i really
applaud you for taking the time to
listen to this podcast if you're here
for mark shepherd and you're a big fan
maybe just maybe you'll listen and
you'll go hey you know what i kind of
like this guy and it was a good
interview and i'm going to give him
another chance that's what we hope ryan
we hope that we get a second chance and
people subscribe
and that they can easily subscribe um
we're on spotify we're on apple we're on
youtube we're on all these things we're
everywhere we're omnipresent
um ubiquitous even ubiquitous i like
that word
um
in our our handles follow us at inside
you podcast on instagram and facebook at
insideapod on the twitter
you know uh we're growing
i think people are starting to realize
that we're not just talking actors
talking about junk we're talking about
real stuff sometimes mental health we
get deep we get uh
i just hope you'll listen next week
instead of if you're just here for mark
shepard maybe uh you'll stick around
also want to tell you that patreon uh it
really helps the show out so join
patreon
um it's it's a place where people
congregate where they online
they uh a lot of people become friends
establish relationships they also get
little perks there's different tiers uh
there's the top tier which you get your
name yelled at on the podcast
at the end and i also send you a box of
merch every couple of months with a
little letter
so there's lots of cool stuff so join
patreon if you want to give back to the
show and that's patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n
dot com slash
inside of you right
yes
patreon.com inside of you that's right
i'm also uh we have a wonderful
wonderful uh on shopify who's also a
sponsor we have the inside of you online
store and you can get uh tons of merch
smallville merch small script signed a
small lunchbox sign you can get inside
of you tumblers and coffee mugs and
tons of great stuff and also sunspin.com
that's my band you can get you can book
the band on a zoom uh i'm also on cameo
but you can get cool merch at
sunspin.com who you know uh stephen
amell wears spin hats i've heard of him
i've heard of him arrow the guy from
arrow what's he like a great guy he's
been in the podcast like what four times
has he i think so huh also i'm gonna be
fan expo in st louis may 13th weekend
friday night we're doing a smallville
nights with tom welling me and tom doing
a two-man show at fan expo st louis may
13th that weekend whatever that friday
is figure it out um also may 21st that
weekend or whatever that is we'll be in
liverpool at a con so hopefully you'll
join us there and of course june 10th
metropolis illinois that's going to be a
sold out show as well uh june 17th uh
for two weeks i'll be in australia perth
and sydney get down there go down under
well we'll hang out mate oh
was that terrible
jennifer lopez jennifer lopez i like
jennifer lopez that's that's the best
way i can get into the australia
i just use the cities i say perth
adelaide sydney italy melbourne
melbourne melbourne melbourne is a good
one yeah
brisbane gold coast brisbane brisbane
yeah anyway
you're bored let's just get into it new
south wales uh this guy is
new south wales
i love this guy mark shepard he's been
on the podcast before a long time ago uh
in the name of the father uh you know
and supernatural he's just done so much
work i don't need to get into it he's a
really great listen he is another uh
individual who opens up and i i thank
you mark for coming on the podcast again
it was a real pleasure i enjoyed having
you in studio
no zoom we're doing a lot of in studios
now so without further ado let's get
inside of mark shepard it's my point of
view you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience you do a lot of voice-overs
some i've got a i spent years
languishing in uh
instead of voice over hell my father was
known for having a the same voice as me
but an octave lower
even lower yeah so he was uh he's doing
hundreds of games and all sorts of fun
stuff but uh
so i was always the kid
and so i finally switched voice over
agents like uh
middle of the pandemic
and i started doing things like call of
duty and really you have to do fun [ __ ]
like that i got to play like a
280 pound
irish specialist in the last irish she
had to do an irish accent well yeah my
family's mostly irish but you don't
speak in it with an irish diet like uh
what's it called irish uh really little
research now i i
well you don't sound really irish well
not not naturally but well that's what
i'm saying naturally fake dublin accent
in the 80s because i was in a big irish
band so you could just jump into it
well jumping into it's weird like the
first film i ever did was a film called
in the name of the father one of my
favorite movies and that's a thick
belfast remember when i pissed on you
just sappy name you poured the second
name and i pissed on it that's when i
knew i was bad though the medal
right on the middle that's right that's
actually a true story which is kind of
brilliant
um a lot of things about that film are
just extraordinary i have to watch it
again because i've seen it many years
ago but you have a decent little part in
that
one of the leads yeah you're one of the
leads
dude you have to watch the name of i
haven't watched it since i was in
college so that's why i didn't remember
i'm one of the guilford four i played
patty armstrong
that's me dude it's me and the afghan
coat when they come to london
and uh dude that's the first person i
sound like an idiot dude that's right uh
ryan yeah have you ever seen in the name
of the father no daniel day-lewis
i urge all of you you know that i i when
i don't like something i tell you when i
like something i tell you in the name of
the father is one of the
great movies a great movie great cast
true story
true story based on true story yeah and
i know the man that i played which was
fascinating to me and unlike any other
role that i kind of ever usually have or
i'm thought of for i played a man with
no actions
he's literally
dale lewis's character playing jerrycon
and like asked me a question in the
squad and he's like you're coming you
know this is happening you're coming i'm
like i don't know
it's like he's he was literally a person
who was steamrolled by an entire system
uh without going on for hours well i
know that i'm i am interested there i am
without going on forever yeah the bottom
line was uh
at the time in 1974
um
uh
21 people were
were killed in ira bomb explosion in
birmingham
and you know this was the largest
fatality
since the blitz
and then in guildford uh
pubs were targeted that were uh british
soldier
pubs squaddies pubs
and seven people were killed in the
guilford bombings so the entire country
was banging for blood
uh this hadn't happened and this was
under the edict that the ira i think
basically had said one bomb on the
mainland is worth 100 in ulster
so if you take the fight to england you
cause
attention whereas there was very little
attention being played to pay to what
was actually going on in northern
ireland at the time
and so these people got caught up the
guilford four and their associated
families were called the maguire seven
and a lot of other people
um let's just put it this way um at the
end of the 70s
i think they had to let out
70 irish people from prison who had been
convicted
wrongfully
wow so it was part of that era
of british and irish politics which is
very very important and my favorite
thing about it whatever your position is
whatever your your belief system is or
whatever your politics are as irrelevant
the bottom line these were people that
were caught up in a mass
uh hysteria moment that had never
happened before in england certainly
since the war
and
two things one
it was the biggest grossing film in
ireland it beat jurassic park because
the biggest crazy birmingham which is
wonderful
uh and and and secondly
it's just one of the pieces of the
jigsaw that makes it harder to convict
people of a crime they didn't commit um
the people that did it
admitted to doing it which is something
they weren't doing at the time they were
usually saying chuckie i love which
means our day will come and go like and
not
referencing their court case at all even
even in the dock they were just like we
don't care but they went out of their
way to say we did this you've got the
wrong people for this
and nobody cared and what was really
funny was the british the british people
jerry conan said to me once he said uh
um the real jury yeah the real jerry
said to me said he said there was a
british people that got us out it wasn't
the irish people who got us out the
british people had enough at this point
wow there's a wonderful british lawyer
called gareth pierce a woman called
gareth pierce who risked everything and
and managed to anyway don't give away
this
no no risked everything and managed to
to get a look at something that nobody
wanted to look at right that's the way
it's about it's about human beings it's
about
the product of the product edition the
product of stuff and it's just and i
think that's really interesting with
films like belfast out and stuff like
this is going on
i think it's really really difficult
to tell an objective view
of any part of quote unquote the
troubles in the north
unless you find a small piece of it and
tell that small piece because it's such
an endemic thing it's such
a
a socially
polarizing and governmentally polarizing
and policy polarizing and hundreds of
years of sedition and all the rest of
this stuff that's going on and
gangsterism and all the rest of the crap
that's gone on over the years i'm i'm
paraphrasing i don't think it's crap but
i'm just saying right uh just to to be
quick to be brief is to say that i think
the greatest stories told up there are
told in music told in heart
told in graffiti
told in so you know as in song as in
plays there are
but fragments and moments that allow you
to piece together how these things could
have happened right and why this area
formats
certain behaviors and certain things the
shank hill butchers you know all these
inc incredible stories that don't i mean
they exist in other formats in other
countries and in other political
situations but not quite like this and
the wit and the hero i was telling billy
connolly about us years ago
the wit and the humor
and the music and the art is beautiful
in the midst of
somewhat chaos what other people view as
chaos but the daily life in belfast in
the 80s is very very different than
anything we've we've ever experienced
this but in our way and i used to play
in a band in ireland it was very big and
very political and was actually
sanctioned under section 31 of the
broadcasting act in ireland several
times etcetera etcetera i hope in the
joshua tree tour with you too
wow very very political band and used to
play
with a particular flag uh
a ploughing stars from
john b the workers flag of ireland is
the fast way of doing it i could do this
for days we could have seven days of
talking about it yeah and i still
you would see the limitations of my
knowledge and understanding you
you've said things that i have no idea
about but it you know i mean everybody
has a
there's been a lot of it's the history
there's been a lot of reasons to keep a
romantic view of it as it's not romantic
at all
but to actually investigate it and see
it yes you investigate it and see it and
there's a brutality and a sadness and a
but there's a beauty and a humor i can't
tell you how dark and beautiful the
humor is
um i'll tell you a connolly story one
day yeah we we always used to stay in
one of two hotels which is the europa or
the wellington park in belfast and
they've got you know 20 feet of chain
fence going upwards outside and barbed
wire the most bombed hotel in europe
is in belfast
and it's
the culture isn't driven by that the
culture is driven by the opposite of
that
the culture is driven by
they want to survive they want to the
want to succeed
and and to be in ireland and southern
ireland to be part of
um it's escapism well to be but to be in
ireland and see us is like almost a
third world country for so long but a
lack of investment lack of funding lack
of anything and then suddenly the 80s
hits and we we beat england
a football
i have a pair of boxer shorts with the
score on it from that day i think he
could have robbed any house in ireland
on that day
you know
jack charlton who was english took
ireland to the world cup
i mean this is a bunch of part-timers
who were playing right i mean and that
was kind of the beginning you two got
signed we got signed jeremy barno many
times he did the music for in the name
of the father
there's a really funny thing jesus we
could talk about in the name of the
father for an hour but we were in we
were in um
we're at the savoy cinema and in the
middle of dublin uh where my dad used to
go to the cinema as a kid
and tuxedos and
you know we're showing showing in the
name of the father in ireland for the
first time and everybody is there and
bono's called down from the stage and
he's in the middle of the europa tours
europa tour right and i come down the
stage and he goes i know you i said yeah
i played paddy in the film and he's like
he's like no you asked he goes i know
you
i said yeah i used to be the drummer and
light a big fire he said yeah i said
once upon a time i opened for you now
you're opening for me
i love that i mean you know but that's
awesome but to be in a country that
check at the time that changes so much
and
it's about youth and is about
it was a good time it's incredible the
80s were incredible and we never i don't
know if we we truly believed there would
be
any version of peace or any version of
of of change in our time but we could
feel something fomenting and changing
yeah and
it took an awful lot of people an awful
lot of work to even get to this point
yeah it's just magical and so i think
the stories about the north the greatest
stories about the north are these little
stories about people not about
the politics necessarily and and they
shine a light on the antidote right to
the suffering and the difficulty and and
and just the some of the mayhem
inside of you is brought to you by
wondering marilyn monroe she is far and
away the most famous actress of the 20th
century her name and image are
synonymous with the american ingenue and
in an all-new season of wondery's even
the rich hosts brooke and irisha
pull back the curtain on her legendary
life and career
much has been said and written about
marilyn in the 60 years since her tragic
death at 36 but what often gets
overshadowed is the absolute force of
nature she was while she was alive
marilyn was a woman ahead of her time in
so many ways from the moment she stepped
onto her first movie set it became clear
that it was her acting and intoxicating
charm that brought her film's box office
success but her rising stardom
threatened movie studio execs who wanted
starlets they could control from major
studios holding her to unjust contracts
to studio execs making sexual advances
maryland privately endured all the worst
parts of hollywood sexism and overcoming
those barriers often forced her to
choose between her dreams and her sanity
the inimitable maryland magic
it wasn't an accident she created it and
it became the biggest
movies the inimitable the inimitable
maryland magic it wasn't an accident she
created it and became the biggest movie
star in the world despite being
underestimated and ridiculed at every
turn even the rich has all the juicy
details of her spectacular but all too
short life
uh i am fascinated by marilyn monroe i
don't know anyone who isn't if you walk
into my house what's the first thing you
see in the living room marilyn monroe a
giant portrait of marilyn monroe
uh i i just loved her uh enamored by her
uh i love stories about her this sounds
like it's gonna be amazing
so
don't take it just for me
i mean millions of people love marilyn
monroe how do you like marilyn monroe
you know who doesn't but who does who's
not fascinated by that listen to even
the rich marilyn monroe on apple
podcasts amazon music or you can listen
ad free by joining wondery plus in the
wondery app inside of you is brought to
you by
magic spoon
you know i love my magic spoon ryan i
know you do you know why
why is that because i could finally have
cereal again and i could feel like a kid
again and this time i'm eating cereal
that's healthy
cereal that i can eat that's not gonna
make me go gosh why did i do that man
it's nostalgic and healthy yeah you know
i think it's just important you know my
my daily routine starts with a big bowl
a magic spoon and i i've
i've noticed fewer cravings throughout
the day um
and more energy to hold me over until
lunch
that's a good thing
trying to cut down on carbs
unhealthy foods sugars and whatnot
why don't you tell us because this is
pretty amazing
look by the way magic spoon when you're
a kid you have all these cereals and you
love these cereals but they're terrible
for you and you're gonna have a freaking
heart attack if you're my age and you
keep taking you keep eating these
cereals but some magic spoon made of
cereal that you can eat as an adult that
you can enjoy and even as a kid you can
enjoy it but it's a little healthier
it's a lot healthier ryan magic spoon
has zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams
of protein and only four net grams of
carbs in each serving only 140 calories
a serving it's keto friendly gluten free
grain free soy free and low carb build
your own box available flavors to build
your very own custom bundle are cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter cookies and
cream maple waffle blueberry cinnamon
plus the newly reformulated honey nut
flavor that will now be added to magic
spoon's permanent collection
i don't know how you don't try this
stuff i've had friends call me text me
come on man it's just magic spoon stuff
good and i always say yeah what do you
want me to tell you it's delicious try
it i had in the studio months back i had
ryan try it and we we both admitted man
this stuff's really good it's delicious
it really is i'm craving it right now i
swear to god i'm craving it go to
magicspoon.com
iou to grab a custom bundle of cereal
and be sure to use our promo code iou at
checkout to save five dollars off your
order and magic spoon is so confident in
their product it's backed with a hundred
percent happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund your money no questions asked
i mean what else do you need to hear
cereal deliciousness money back
guarantee remember get your next
delicious bowl of guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com
iou and use the code iou to save five
dollars off and thank you magic spoon
for sponsoring this episode we do love
you
i noticed that you always bring up like
uh you bring up your dad a lot
and you i look on instagram
boom there's the pictures of your dad
well last time we talked he had just
passed away
and
he was yeah how are you dealing with
that now
it's really weird
my dad was a wonderful actor he was a
really interesting actor never really
made it made it but actors knew who he
was and and just loved his work and he
was in everything for a long time
that guy right oh yeah yeah he's in this
oh he's in the prestige oh he's a
needful thing so he's in he's in all
these movies and all these games and
this voice like this yeah morgan shepard
here
and
we weren't very close when i was a kid
and then we became very very close when
he moved over here to do max headroom
and we sort of fix whatever problems we
have by working together
acting together directing together doing
all this crazy stuff we did over the
years and and so
any successful moment any happy moment
any sad moment i'm used to picking up
the phone he either lived downstairs for
me across the road from me
or down the road from me for the last
25 years so it's hard to go laurel
canyon together but i'm used to picking
up the phone and saying oh so blah blah
blah
and i don't have that do you still think
about it like i pick up a phone all the
time but
my dad was in serious distress by the
time that he passed
and his passing was such a relief i
could feel it was such a relief for him
he was done at 86 i think um
that i wouldn't have wished him an extra
day i wouldn't have wished him an extra
minute the selfish side of course i want
him around forever of
but to have to be a person who studied
history and had stories and and pulled
people together and which people just
loved him
um
to not have that in the last five six
months of his life very very quickly he
descended into
um
you know he just didn't get enough
oxygen and blood to his brain he had
some he had some issues and problems and
and they all got worse and instead of
being able to have open-heart surgery he
ended up passing before that was
possible and that this was like three
years ago two and a half years ago two
years ago i think yeah two or three
years ago um
it escapes me it feels like yesterday
and sometimes it feels like 10 years ago
but it's not
it's not tragic there's nothing tragic
about it and when i think of my dad i
think of really positive things i think
of fun things
i think of things he said i you know i
just worked with timothy dalton for the
last couple of years i remember seeing
tim dalton there's a great picture of my
dad and tim dalton if you look it up
doing the romans of the mermaid
in england which i saw as a kid and
my dad was playing caesar it was just
like but i that i know him from then and
i end up working with him later
and every time i see john reese davis
it's like please remind your father he's
far far older than i it would be
but um
he was connected to so many people but
never as a as a big star he was just
somebody that people liked and did i
mean he did gettysburg he narrated
gettysburg he's the first voice in
gettysburg
so i know
those are big shoes to fill right right
that was the whole thing did you feel
like that you were going out you didn't
show up absolutely not i refused to be
an actor for that reason um
but i don't act like him
we've taught together i mean i'm more of
a i guess a check of trained actor and
he's he was in peterborough's royal
shakespeare company so he did marathon
broadway did all the all that great
stuff that ever existed he worked with
luther hagen he taught
the actors studio in new york he did all
this stuff so he's part of that era of
theater
but his transition into film was a tough
thing for him because he always wanted
to be an american and so when he finally
got over here to do
max headroom
he did max headroom here and then he did
gun smoke he did the last max headroom
the voice no he was uh he was blank reg
in max headroom really punk guy with the
six wheel bus the radio station yeah so
he came over to do that he i think he
signed a gersh and then he was in the
last gunsmoke movie he's in so many
things that are just
fun and he reinvented himself again
again if what what it was like you know
i i started acting because i did this
play and then it got big and stuff
happened
and i remember the front page of the
calendar so i'm not an actor i'm a
musician my dad's an actor
and i just got like drama critic circle
award or something stupid so i was like
it was just one of those things where
i didn't want the path he had because i
didn't like you
like
watching the negatives of what our job
is when you see people that don't love
it or struggle with it or start to get
angry because the work isn't there or
frustrated because they're getting older
or whatever and the time is getting
harder for them and there's no there's
less and less joy involved in it right
and then the other side of that is
watching somebody who's happy when
they're working and miserable when
they're not which i hate have you ever
been that guy yeah many times my kids
will tell you that
really yeah my kids will come out so
what what what made you miserable
because you haven't drank in 32 years
right but waiting is an action that
consumes all other actions
waiting the action of meeting destroys
and consumes anything else yeah so being
busy doesn't work for me i'm too smart
to con myself into the idea that i'm
busy
but actually doing something and being
sober as part of that as you realize
you know just for me in particular if i
sit still and the world revolves around
me i get into a hole and then drinking
looks like a
does that make sense yeah because if it
did for you what it does for me you'd be
doing it right now
wow if it did does for you with heroin
alcohol
butane
zippo lighter fluid you did anything you
can get your hands on but i didn't
think it was like that but on reflection
looking back i was trying to find
something from the age of 12 that would
fill that void and then i pick a
profession well as a musician but then i
picked a professor i told him my first
job
i came second
and it destroyed me you didn't get it
it went to tim roth
first film was it rosencrantz and
guildenstern no pre-that it was it was
made in britain which was a fantastic
piece and i didn't get it so i got a
phone call from the casting director the
next year said
so you drive right i'm like no good i'm
glad you can drive it was one of those
calls where they're obviously in front
of a bunch of producers they said so we
want to go to spain and do this movie
and i'm like now i'm doing an album
refused absolutely refused to do it
would never step into that arena again
and that was the hit with terrence stamp
tim roth's second film
i'm entirely responsible for tim ross
career no he's a fabulous actor he's a
wonderful actor and there's a reason why
they were right for him and they weren't
right for me but then to
do all that stuff tour the world do all
this stuff i do live in ireland blah
blah blah come back to america and then
do this play
sober
and then go wow this is like jumping off
a building and finding out you got wings
it's not like jumping off a building and
hoping you don't hit the pavement it's
literally like jumping off a building
and going
take a breath breathe out everything you
need is here
and it was kind of scary and the weird
thing is my drumming suffered as a
result because i didn't pick up a pair
of drumsticks for 20 years
because my drumming was all connected to
my drug use i didn't i mean i'd
patch it and it was billy moran and um
and mike bought her and steve i love
those dogs
want to get up and play disarm i know
i'm good
so when i got up and played they were
like oh you play i'm like well yeah i've
always played i hadn't picked up a pair
of drumsticks in 20 years and then
suddenly i'm back playing with robin
hitchcock and doing all this stuff
it's i'm really weird like that my
anxiety and my stress so i picked the
worst
yeah you so you have a lot of anxiety
still yeah yeah of course i do and i've
got you know i got three kids
and you don't have drinking to kind of
to buffer me from it but you you and i
have said recently we've sat in a bar
and watched unnamed actors
totally unnamed actors will never be
named
you know i wouldn't even say what get
smashed
no not get smashed but
getting smashed is easy
but you can you watch them deteriorating
into a place
that you it just doesn't fit some people
you can see and you can see the one or
two of them
start behaving badly stop being
uncomfortable doing that stuff
that's me
yeah i also see other people
stressful day have a beard have a beer
do whatever you buddy tom brilliant
what's your mother drink he's the
happiest dude
oh my goodness
i watch i'm so jealous of the fact that
you can actually sit there and not
destroy things being your size
well you know by the way he adores you
he just was he crashed at the house
and he just left this morning but when i
told him his eyes just lit up and he was
like he's so great he just he's so
forthcoming he just you know he just
he's such a sweet guy well tom's a
really honest dude it's really weird
because you wouldn't expect when you see
him in smallville when you think of
you know i start then i started to think
of god the pressures he must have had to
be that for that long in that situation
so i've i've you know i'm not using
number one on a call sheet there's been
a couple of times i've been close to
being but but it's not generally the
vibe here
and what i loved about you with with lex
luthor is you at least had room to play
you are not constrained by
the rules of number one on the call
sheet or number two on the call sheet
where you're the last person to have any
information yeah
okay it's like really
oh no we're doing that now
yeah right but yours is like
you know
you've invented a new version of how to
screw with number one well you were kind
of like the lex luthor of supernatural
it wasn't designed that way but it's
kind of where it ended but crowley was
sort of you know he was middle
management when he started and like me
like lex i you had to give all these
monologues you spoke a lot oh god do you
miss that jensen wants to ask me he was
he was being very polite but he asked me
one day he goes okay i've got to ask you
this
so bob and i were wondering
how come
when you when you're doing your
off-camera dialogue you're perfect
everything's right and then we turn
around onto you it takes you three takes
four takes to get it
and one time he asked me this when he
was he had a couple of drinks so he was
nicely lubed up
and it was at three in the morning and
something stupid
and i said listen
you're the lead
you're basically talking bollocks
they give me a story that they think is
funny they give me lines that they think
is incredibly funny when they've written
it on paper i now have to read that find
a way to believe it and find a way to
make it actually mean something
otherwise i'm halfway through going
it means nothing to me
so
i said that's the reason why i'm
carrying the bloody plot or i'm carrying
the cut the counter plot or i'm carrying
the c story or i'm carrying it's for how
many years i did eight you did eight
seasons
don't listen i'm telling you i love
those guys i love those guys with all my
heart yeah absolutely yeah ups and downs
i mean the the the thing at the end was
the weird thing what was the weird thing
i'm gonna do with the boys had nothing
to do with anything else they didn't ask
you to come back well no it was worse
than that it was kind of tacky
it was
it was like well we don't think we have
enough money to pick up your option next
year
are you serious well because they were
working out how to do what they were
going to do with the story that they
needed to continue beyond you know into
the 13th and 14th seasons and rest
and i think a particular show runner
remained nameless um was trying to kill
me for about four or five years and it
was just funny because i kind of knew
because i knew the rest of the writers
but i didn't care about that wasn't the
problem i had the point being is i went
from being a guest star that refused to
sign a contract for five years
to now i'm three years i mean warner's
put me on the poster before my deal was
done they put me on the video box they
were just like well you can't sort of
ignore it
and then it was like take it or leave it
and i think it was majorly about getting
the boys out on a friday more than
anything else
which is smart i mean for god's sakes
they've been working for you know 10 11
12 years at the time and they worked
their ass off and they just moved back
to texas and all that i mean it's just
smart stuff they've got families and
they're starting families but i used to
get away with going i can't do that i'm
going to my kids suck a game on friday
so i won't be there
and then
they were like take it or leave it and i
was going through a divorce at the time
i was like i could just disappear
or i could just pay my bills and what
i'm supposed to do and take the job and
say thank you very much so i was grumpy
for a little bit and they tolerated me
being in a bad mood for a year or so and
then i started to make friends and
things were wonderful
and
then they come to the end they go like
well we don't know if we can
take up your option
and i was like and i said to bob i think
that's what piss bob offers i said
if you take me off the poster i'm not
coming back
because i don't do windows
and that was
not received well
really you just said that well yeah it's
exactly what i said because the truth
you felt like you'd earned it well the
funny thing was i mean
with all due respect to my friends i am
so grateful for myself and for all my
friends that they had work for this
amount of time it was good work and that
everybody on that crew was was just
fantastic they were all at my wedding
for god's sake yeah you know it was it
was a big deal plus the fans the fans
but the fans fans are amazing yeah
that's that's that's without saying
but
i was playing i played the same scene in
season 12 five times over five episodes
and i was like all right gig's up you
know the gig is up
and so you know everyone's kind of had
they won't get rid of you then when i
get ready i'm like i'm done i know i'm
done you knew it yeah i know it was done
transpo
that's what season was this 12 12 i was
killed at the end of 12th and transpo
when
like take your car home
well i don't have transport then i say
we'll do it
so i took my car home like a month and a
half early two months early i was taken
to and from set every single day i was
taken home i was dropped at airports
brought back it was just
i was looked after that was sweet it is
sweet and people don't have to do that
they and they did and it was
and i think what surprised everybody on
set on my last scene is i'd already
spent two weeks saying goodbye to
everybody i didn't want to make a speech
for the first time in my life and i
think they got a little upset that i
didn't make some big speech because i'm
big mouth you didn't say anything i said
thank you very much and walked away i
spent two weeks talking to every single
person so you didn't have to say
anything i didn't feel i had to say
anything but i think it got a bit weird
and then i don't know i just do do you
get invited to the supernatural
conventions
i don't
no
you don't no i i did 17 and then it was
really weird for my friends
it was weird for my friends what do you
mean
okay so ruth plays my mother wonderful
lovely actress beautiful human being
worked her butt off on the show chris
should have been my uh
ex-wife who would have been even better
it would have been fantastic she should
have played my ex-wife in the show it
would have been just something else
right but okay she's my mom doesn't
really make sense in the candy she's my
mom but we made it work and she's just
brilliant she's just wonderful to work
with
and really do i want to go to a
convention where every single question
she gets is when's mark shepard coming
back
because that's what happened for a year
yeah that's not cool
they've got work to do they've got
things to do they deserve better than
that right so i opted out of those at
first
it was very uncomfortable for a bit and
then i opted out of it after i'd done my
2017 stuff and i went on tour robin
robin hitchcock and i didn't act for a
year or so i was miserable it was like
everybody was having a party and i
wasn't invited
not some of the commercial until i met
just generally this is and that's not
nobody's fault and i genuinely with my
whole heart i've never begrudged them
a moment a minute
right do you talk to them still yeah i
told everybody i talked to everybody
yeah i talked to
jared on occasion
people coming to the house i see kim all
the time kim's daughter swims with my
son kim coats yeah i love kim um
just did rob rich's podcast after a
period of time which was fun to do i
want to interview them just to annoy him
richard spate and i love him and i had
them on the podcast and rob benedict
they're fantastic great people i mean
i've played with them but like in any
real family you have ups and downs and
dynamics and the smiles absolutely the
smart thing for me to do was to back
away because they were an ongoing
position and they were still pushing and
they managed to go to 15 years
and it wasn't for me to be you know the
thorn in the side did you ever lose your
temper and yell on set
you're like this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
no i don't think so never
well i have lost my temper about a
couple of things but it but i did it but
never answer no that's not i don't think
it's my thing i mean the trouble is
though my face and my tone people think
i'm annoyed when i'm
people think you're just not happy yeah
and i'm mark are you okay
yeah there was a director that i really
hated oh i bet i worked with him yeah he
did um
and
he was dancing around this idea of doing
this particular stunt but he hadn't told
anybody and then suddenly he takes me
aside
and apparently pellegrino was supposed
to stick
one of our
demon
artifacts you know the pointy thing you
kill people with yeah what are those
called ryan
blades
demon blades
richard blades yes
dashing blades but i mean i've got i've
dropped more of those out of my sleeves
than anything you can imagine so he
literally had the kung fu dummy you know
the bob kung fu dummy in front of him
and this contraption and supposedly he
was going to stick this thing up my nose
which had a breakaway tip and squirt
blood on my nose and it was going to be
pellegrino that did it and i'm like
that's not going on my nose
you're not sticking a solid piece of
metal up my nose to do
a gag from chinatown which is what it is
um
oh
god sex it's actually called jim jim
michael's down
never done that before who's jim
michaels he was the producer the de
facto line producer producer and i'm
like am i in trouble because i'm not
doing this you guys know
so two weeks we've been arguing about
this crap don't worry about it and then
mark milosh the wonderful
um visual effects guy came down and goes
i can do a green screen just use the
rubber one i knew you were going to say
that thank you so much
but it got caustic you know there's
moments there's ups and downs but
it's easy to get but the behavior on
that set was exemplary nobody would
tolerate jared and jensen wouldn't
tolerate somebody losing their temper
it's just not okay you don't throw
things
and everybody knows it he did that the
crew go
what's wrong with you
you know you don't
but it's hard people say you got to
separate business from you know and it's
sometimes hard because you know i i
dealt with it with uh you know warner
brothers and going through negotiations
and they just they know how to really
[ __ ] you they know how to make you
mentally
just
never did it to me because i'm not that
important well they they had a way but
it's it's amazing how it could change
your spirits because i was always doing
stand-up comedy on set and everybody's
like laughing and i'm like farting and
doing christopher walken and action and
i'm like luther and then all of a sudden
you're worthless you're not important to
us you're not without how many fights
did you get why don't i get bumped this
year it just well it was it was a lot
but it was
also one day one of the uh the my friend
greg beeman who's one of my favorite
directors and producers
he came up to me and we've done some
projects together he said
hey
i know what's going on
but they've got nothing to do with it
the studio doesn't give a [ __ ] how you
feel they don't know you you're on set
but i could see your disposition your
you don't let that affect you yeah no i
continued to have and i it was
an awakening for me
but it still it was it was i was going
through a divorce and then
on different occasions both jared
janssen and misha
i've gone you're right
and literally made sure i was okay horse
somebody said something that had
happened which hadn't happened and one
of those things and it's like you know
one of them takes me out of dinner
and i was like is this going on here
okay so you have people who cared about
it always and that's the thing and it
was it was a big boys club i mean we
played hard i mean watch any of the nerd
hq
videos and that's like right we've done
a year's worth of publicity in two days
yeah misha and i get to do one day of
stuff and they have to only have to come
in on the second day and do it but we
are like running out of things to do
after year seven
you know and it's what can we do but we
are the custodians of of
these are the plot points these are the
changes this is what's going on don't
talk about this do talk about that and
it was wonderful and i i don't i don't
regret a second of doing it i don't
i miss the camaraderie of the time
around season eight when we were all in
the in the
you know the season eight is the end
where um i'm tied to a chair in a church
and jared myself and
you know it was three days
three days on stage
in sequence
i'm crying quoting girls hbo's girls
it's nuts i'm singing bowie it's i'm
being injected with human blood and
falling apart and he's falling apart and
jensen did six hours of off-camera
dialogue one day i mean you're talking
about class what was the amazing thing
crew never made a sound for three days
in between the in between the shots
wow did make a sound
wanted us to be able to do the best we
could do that's right we had support
everywhere yeah we had support
everywhere i mean that's that's that's a
big part of it i can't i can't talk
i can't talk more highly about the boy's
behavior yeah especially towards
those that weren't very good necessarily
when they came they would they would be
even more generous unbelievable it was
always that's the way they come from
good family good leaders no they have
great families yeah and that you can
tell you me have you ever met either
chancellor jared's family i just
you could tell he's raised good people
and they're just good people and so
jared has a few beers and then you're
here
it's easy i love jared i love you buddy
inside of you is brought to you by
better help better help online therapy i
can't tell you how many emails or texts
or messages i get
from people telling me that better help
is helping them
and i really love that i love uh
talking about something that works that
helps people that is a sponsor on the
podcast where we talk about mental
health
it's very important ryan's still with
better help i'm still a better help and
it's still
helping still helping help i like
hearing that you know people don't
always realize that physical symptoms
like headaches
teeth grinding even digestive issues can
be indicators of stress and let's not
forget about doom scrolling sleeping too
little sleeping too much under eating
overeating stress shows up in all kinds
of ways and in a world that's telling
you to do more sleep less and grind all
the time here's your reminder to take
care of yourself to do less and maybe
try some therapy better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to ryan you like to see people i do i
think it helps i do too i like to see
the person i'm talking to but that's
just me if you don't feel like seeing a
face you don't have to you could also
text you could have it you could do
whatever you want it's so much more
affordable than in-person therapy
trust me on that one uh going in uh
in-person therapy is is so expensive
it's i i'd say some cases it's triple
quadruple the cost of better health by
far uh you could be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours give it a
try and see if online therapy can help
lower your stress i believe it really
can truly this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp and inside of you listeners
get 10 percent off their first month at
betterhelp.com
inside that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash
in sign give therapy a shot
better help online therapy
inside of you is brought to you by geico
geico asks how would you love a chance
to save some money on insurance of
course you would after all who doesn't
love a great deal right and when it
comes to great rates on insurance for
all the things in your life
geico can help like with insurance for
your car truck motorcycle boat and rv
even help with homeowners condo or
renter's coverage you could save even
more with a special discount when you
bundle your coverages plus add the easy
to use geico mobile app available
24-hour roadside assistance and more and
choosing to switch to geico becomes an
easy choice switch today and see all the
ways you could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy
simply go to geico.com to get a rate
quote or contact your local agent and
get started seeing how much you could
save
hey
what about working with um
i know you worked on firefly and badger
with joss whedon
what was i mean now that all this [ __ ]
came out
do you remember anything that you kind
of saw as you know rubs you the wrong
way and you're like oh you know in
hindsight that was or what did you never
see anything like that was he a joy i
did i did firefly and i did dollhouse
dollhouse right so
here's the thing with just i'm not one
of justice guys
i wasn't in buffy i wasn't an angel i
wasn't any of that stuff i'm not one of
joss's
go-to i'm not any of those things right
but the role he wrote in fire firefly he
wrote for himself
and i adam baldwin's is a buddy of mine
and he said uh
about halfway through the 12 hours of
shooting the scene
he goes like you know he wrote it for
himself i'm like okay fine
he's extraordinarily smart
ridiculously smart in the same thing
intimidating
i don't think so i don't but i've never
had an issue
i don't
i don't i'm not that guy i i don't think
if you hire me to do a job
i'm supposed to be the most interesting
5 10 20 30 40 minutes of whatever that
job is that's my position right that's
under my ego that's to do with
i'm not very good at standing in the
back and holding a book or do it's not
my thing
so if you hire me i'm the object of
attention and i'm going to take the air
but i'm not i'm not ungenerous i'm not
i'm not dismissive yeah but
you know we did the end of season did
the end of season nine where where
jensen's in the bed in supernatural
right and he opens his eyes and the
black demon everybody goes nuts and got
warner brothers to find all the reaction
videos for him put on the dvd because it
was so much fun
and tom wright was the director remember
tom wright he painted all the pictures
in night gallery
oh wow
wonderfully
older gentleman who is just brilliant
right he did baby did the episode baby
that everybody loves he's done some
amazing stuff
he's just funny and brilliant and and he
worked for hitchcock as a storyboard
artist i mean he's that sort of pedigree
and he's just a fantastic human being
and fun to play with and this scene is
here and it's me talking for whatever it
is 27 000 minutes
giving a speech and making him open his
eyes
and i said what do you want me to do
and tom goes well i see the opening shot
as you in silhouette in the doorway
rest is up to you have fun
i then spend five minutes trying to find
a place i want to be
and then go
and then suddenly i find this armchair
and i go my god this speech is all about
truth it is abraham lincoln i'm
literally thinking of the link
oh my god i've got two arms oh this is
weird no i won't be on the couch i'll be
over he let me play for five minutes
he works out how to shoot it that's not
because i'm you know i i get to be in
charge right but he's like here's your
parameters go have fun
that's what we always want to hear is
i'm not the guy some people they're
frightening have you had like have you
ever had line readings from a director
sometimes uh they couldn't articulate
what the [ __ ] they wanted and it was
terrible direction so i said hey tell me
exactly how you want me to say the
[ __ ] line
and i would i would great and i'd just
go boom boom twice the way they said it
just to move on i don't care i'm like
let's go yeah just give me a line
reading i was dying in 24 and the
director of the episode another one of
two we'll get back to joss whedon yeah
but there's nothing to say about that
all right fine because i mean like so i
get a phone call i just want you to be
in dollhouse i'm like okay can i see it
again it says tanaka i'm like well
obviously wasn't the first choice for
this was i
so i show up at fox
and i go and he meets me at the gate and
he's like hey so you know we're doing
this i'm keeping the name because i knew
you were going to say that
so i was like he said
uh
yeah maybe you step there with japanese
or something i said oh i married a
japanese guy he goes this is fox you
can't do that
but he was he was always incredibly
respectful i mean
he was so you never saw that part he
wrote nice things about me to other
people that wrote with me and they
passed it on right but he the only thing
he was asked to do battle star back in
the day do an episode of the
which you did and he said you did the
reboot
the the proper battle start yeah the one
we got emmys for right right right
rather than costume
um
so
he was going to do one of the finale-ish
episodes somewhere in that last group
you know
and i think i can't swear to it but i
was thinking he actually asked do i have
to know the ending to do this episode i
think rod said yes because i don't want
to do it i genuinely don't want to do it
it would spoil i arrived at dar house
he's like if you tell me the end about
it i'll kill you
i'm like am i gonna tell you the best
kept secret for six months wow it was
brilliant nobody wanted to know nobody
wanted to know it was like
do you know i've never seen a series
you'd love it it's west wing in space
it's west wing in space i saw the pilot
and i was blown away the pilot
the mini series is the opener yeah and
then the episode one is uh about the
sensory deprivation all right i'm going
to watch it don't say anything i think
it's brilliant but it's serialized you
cannot jump into it it's just
right it's like cliffhangers and oh
right right right
what were you going to say about 24.
because i want to know what it was like
because kiefer was on the podcast i want
to know kind of like yours keith and i
go great keeper knows i'm sober and
never has ever spent a minute i mean i
keep hearing all these things that
people say about him and i've never
encountered that
what he has and i i can't really speak
for him
but i can say what happened around is he
doesn't like it when people behave
unprofessionally and there's plenty of
actors that are like that it's like
please be quiet
we're trying to work here christian bale
yeah i mean i understand that you just
don't want to do it when your mic's on
right
or go as extreme perhaps well he's so
far down in the hole in what he's doing
i mean it's i've been we've all been
there i've been like this i've been but
it's more of a you're upset but you know
like so it's like
al for the [ __ ] of [ __ ]
what are you doing you know banging
nails into but good lord son and then
you laugh it off and you go on but he
just went mental you know wait it it's
just
we always get the tip of the iceberg
you know not to be crude but you [ __ ]
one goat
you know no now you're the goat [ __ ]
well it doesn't matter what else you've
done in your life but you've well you
kill one person you're a murderer
exactly well that's kind of different
you know
as opposed to the goat died
yeah yeah well
but the truth of it is is is the
intensity the intensity in performance
the intensity and we never have enough
time in television and in the in the
belief
you know you come in as a guest are you
in a very very different position than
you are somebody who has to work 16
hours a day
five days a week for x amount of years
sure you're getting the money but you
have to go to your trailer and do all
your business all your home stuff and no
life you've got no adolescents right
right you know and so
i think
producers were very clever with with
jared and jensen and misha at least
giving them the option of some spots
here and there so my character was
written up i think to just give some
relief yes yes from that could you do it
right now could you do if somebody
offered you a lead role in a tv series a
one-hour drama i'd do it in a minute you
could do it yeah physically and mentally
you think you could handle
those hours those being the lead i'm
never happier
never happier and the weird thing is is
i'm getting a bit older
how old are you 58 coming are you 58 so
as i'm getting a bit older you know like
58. i'm 50 in july you're a baby though
no that's not a baby i'm half as [ __ ]
so like hockey that's the problem
yeah but uh
no there's a 58 years old
i love doing the telling stories doesn't
matter it's music you've got you've got
your bands you've got great stuff going
on i've watched your
progression through the different
versions of the bands and playing and
you love it i just enjoy it yeah but you
know you don't enjoy it you love it you
enjoyed it
you know you do it occasionally but you
love it and you pursue it
in a way where i'm not going to be upset
by the outcome of what happens i know
that i'm doing it out of passion you
don't have to sleep in a bus exactly you
can go straight
if you want to right exactly um but the
truth is
to get a chance to act is a is a is an
extraordinary thing
you know
um
to
be paid to do something
that you love to do is a privilege
beyond all other privileges but let me
ask you
do you are you an actor because i know
some actors i'm an actor yes
do you know because i know actors that
are just like i want to work to work i
just want to work to work i don't care
what it is i want to work do you or
don't do it i'm not that
you have to love it or you have to be
passionate about it or you have to see
something that you could do with it
right on the premise that every every
time an actor gets a job another actor
dies a little um yeah good man where it
brings us all up yeah well done no we
don't feel that it's like damn
but
i'm not i don't know why i'm not
i've never been good at commercials i've
never been good at soaps i've never been
good at any of those things it's not
that i've never did a substitute i never
did commercial jensen was like my god
that boy did like 68 pages because he
wanted to go away for five days or
something one day i'm like you did 68
pages of soap dialogue in a day i don't
know how he did that he's amazing i
don't know how he did that he commits
it's about committing to it and the
words are rubbish
to me the words are everything and i
have to find it takes me a minute i have
to find
some truth in something a truth not the
truth but a truth
to connect with i otherwise why am i
saying it or what i don't i don't i feel
so self-conscious when
something isn't in a reality that makes
some sort of sense to me it can take me
by surprise i don't need to control it i
don't need to direct it or make it be
something i'll find it sometimes to be
something really funny when it wasn't
supposed to be but the truth of the
matter is i own it and if i unless i own
it i can't and that cuts me out of about
60 percent of the work that's come
across my
you know and there's roles that came up
the huge stuff for me could have been
groundbreaking changes in mind what's
this what's this doom patrol jim
patrol's amazing god damn it what is
doom patrol i haven't seen doom patrol
do you know anything about it
no so i don't want you to give it away
but how do you how would you describe it
it's a 1960s comic
it was a 1960s comic that got redone by
grant morrison you know the guy did
happy and that's that right grant
wonderful scottish comic book graphic
novel
tv shows rights rights rights right
that's right sort of sort of another
irvine welsh another he's another neil
gaiman in a way but but maybe less
prolific but just as interesting and
he's very much the antidote to to alan
moore whether he likes it or not they
were very
contrary you know there's a you know
watchman and his stuff was very
different and he read it in the 80s on
vertigo comics and doom patrol was
actually the original prototype i think
that x-men stole from
really there's a chief in a wheelchair
there's you know
elastic woman
and you're a regular uh i'm bizarre i'm
doing my usual i'm not gonna i don't
even wanna mock shepard but you do a lot
of episodes i'm playing constantine
wow but he's not called constantine
because grant wasn't allowed to put
constantine in vertigo comics in the 80s
so he was watching with nail and i of
course which you love and so he drew as
richard e grant so i got hold of grant
and i was like a buddy of mine was doing
um green lantern with him my buddy liam
sharp the artist was doing green lantern
with the one they just done that's just
brilliant everybody goes over right
right make a film now yeah um so
i can't cry
like so it's
it's uh
it's richard e grant in
and with now he's like yep i'm like okay
i said with all the love in my heart i
don't think i can play quite that defeat
i think it'd probably be a bit more like
a drunk mad eye moody
he's like sounds good to me and he's not
actually producer on the show but he's
he's so that's kind of your character
it's constantine it's consistent
where do we find it where do we find
this
well the show was put out on dc as a and
they tried to pre-tease it by doing it
with teen titans and they put cyborg
into it jovan wade is wonderful and they
put him across and they tried to do it
that way the typical dc way of doing it
and nobody watched it
and they did this first season so you've
got
timothy dalton
matt bomer in bandages mark shepard no
matt no matt bomer
uh brendan fraser
diane guerrero from orange's new black
and encanto and a lot of other things
april bolby two and a half men remember
candace yep candy and
turn off so good cast no and then the
bad guys
two dick playing this alan tudor claimed
this diminutive mr nobody which is
really wonderful performance by him
jovan way playing cyborg
and who's running it jeremy carver who
ran
the interesting parts of of of
supernatural the eight through 10 11.
wow
and it was like
oh my god and i'll just tell you this
the entire town disappears up the ass of
a donkey in the second episode
have you seen that
uh i started it i hadn't finished it yet
so hbo bought it they went what the hell
this is genius really so it's not super
girl it's not the boys it's something
else it's about mental health
and it is truly disturbing and
beautiful
and funny and begs the question which is
why things have changed why isn't
brendon frazier in everything yeah well
he's because he's a resurgence now
there's a research as a result of doom
he's like he's he's this beautiful heart
in this i love this show i truly love
this
show and
it is
we've done three seasons three seasons
going into the four seasons wow
and
i'm a recurring character that you can't
kill so
yes doesn't you have a deep voice like
that i have my voice that's a deep voice
i actually got to say the c word in my
first line [ __ ] i literally had to
email jeremy and go i i'm saying i've
avoided the c word for 35 years
at this point for 40 years
and he said oh let me have a look oh
yeah it's still in the script
this is says humor i guess i'm like okay
it was the weirdest thing to do was it
exciting now no
you know that americans can't say it
right i know everyone in england can say
it or no no no can't say it literally
cannot say it because they get guilty
the moment it slips out of their mouth
you saw me say to you a few seconds ago
yeah
you look slightly uncomfortable was i
uncomfortable slightly
because there's a knowledge that it's a
bad word in england it's a different
thing let me hear it ryan say it
that's going to sound weird say it [ __ ]
yeah that was oh he's a [ __ ]
but everybody it sounds better when you
say it
yeah but i mean he's a [ __ ] yeah but i
don't say it no i don't sound like he's
a guy
he's a real [ __ ] well last about two
years ago
[ __ ] cuntish and [ __ ] made it into
the oxford english dictionary
your [ __ ] daughter do you know what
she did that's from the exorcist he goes
you're [ __ ] daughter yes that's like
very old language but it's a little that
was a little [ __ ]
there's
it's a weird word because it polarizes
so many people the reason why i don't
use it is because it's used appallingly
right it's used in an atrocious manner
and now it has taken on
a meaning other than the vernacular that
it was should we bleep it for this
episode every time we say it no i mean i
don't
know
but do i you know am i gonna have to
have a conversation about
how it uh how this
affects
women or whatever it's it's it should
never have been i'm not i don't i'm not
a believer in the banning of language
right
it's intent that's important
intent is everything yeah you should be
able to say what you want i mean we you
know language is there for that reason
but it does kind of put you in a corner
if you say certain things sure hey this
is called [ __ ] talking with mark shepard
you've played it before these are rapid
fire from fans my patrons who give back
to the podcast join patreon.com inside
of you and uh message me and i will
message you back but these are questions
that they have for you the patrons
that's the sunspin that's my band's
coaster
you like that real slate real slate how
much are you selling those for
not much eight bucks that's pretty good
you put cheese on it too you could put
cheese on there and cut it yeah cut the
cheese
leanne i have been hearing some
rumblings of a possible firefly reboot
do you foresee that happening i'm 58
years old
what does that mean like yeah if they do
it they're certainly not going to use me
in it
why not because i'm 58 years old you
don't look 58 what are we gonna have
we're gonna have firefly the retirement
years i mean what's going on here
well how old was your character then
when they reboot anything they reboot he
was young i did the god how many years
ago did we do that
15 20 years ago
15 years ago probably but would you do
it if they asked you i'd do anything if
they asked me to do it if it's something
that's
something i love
yeah i want to do this by the way i want
to go to this place but lisa h says i
just want to say i met you last july at
mad monster in arizona and you were a
delight your panel was phenomenal and i
absolutely loved how you called out the
tiring
same old questions
oh i just i have this non-stop thing of
going like
that's a terrible question why are you
you know
you know what it is you get bored if
you're sitting on the stage and you have
somebody asking questions like we could
do this and then we put an audience in
front what are we giving them nothing
you and i would know
that like you know nerd hq you play with
them that's the fun the fun is that you
involve and play so i'm i'm doing the
morton downey jr meets phil donahue grab
a microphone and go walking that's what
i do yeah i go high five babies you have
fun go see people dressed as you enjoy
it because you like that does castiel
are an open season target for me and
misha played cassio yeah so i'm like
what did you come as
and you get these wonderful girls will
go like
castiel and i've never heard of her
you just [ __ ] with people no it's it's
an it's a sort of
unwritten agreed rule
that
they're important to me they're not
strangers they're important to me we're
all in this together
let's entertain the people sitting at
the back let's entertain everybody let's
do something that's fun yeah if somebody
gets on a microphone that's they're
nervous i'll go over and and you're like
okay what's going on what's going on
what do you really want to know i notice
that when i'm signing autographs at
conventions i'll look over when i see
you
and you take your time with every
person like it's unbelievable like you
really do you know how much courage it
takes
to dress up
go to a convention and tell the entire
world in front of you
what you like
what your favorite thing is
meet somebody who you've never met
before and you have an opinion about or
an idea about yeah and you go up and
you've been practicing saying something
for an amount of time and say you suffer
from anxiety or depression or any of the
things which the themes of supernatural
tend to support a lot of these
communities because it's about
family and fighting and not giving up
and all these things and a sense of
community which is important
but then they come up and they practice
something for
for three months and they say something
it's a non-sequitur because it i say
something first by accident
like oh nice hat and they're like
you're a big [ __ ] i'm like oh [ __ ] that
was a line from something
they're just trying to do a line
okay okay i got it my job is to is to
welcome and
yeah do you remember what i did
when i threw something at you playfully
but i didn't know you were talking to
somebody who just was talking to you
about something that was just really
heavy it was like somebody's father or
my mother just died and i'm just trying
to get his attention but i don't hear
this and i i flick a rubber band paper
wad at him and it like goes and he just
turns his head and you kind of just
looked at me like look at death not now
yeah you know because like yeah we
weren't being a dick you were no you
could do whatever that we'd do whatever
the hell we want i was just going to go
but if you hit that person with that
it's going to be the worst day of their
life yeah michael rosemond who i mean
you know i said my mother no let me say
like you never know where people are at
no you never if they're willing to share
with you where they're at then
it's a lovely thing dana asked what was
the worst job that you have ever had as
a job job could be anything what was the
worst job you oh that sucked
built designed and maintained video
duplication systems in the valley when i
first got sober that's a little tongue
twister right there uh i've been a
motorcycle courier pretty weird in
london
um
i haven't had a lot of jobs i ran a bar
in hollywood for a long time really what
was it called the powerhouse the
powerhouse gary twin was that was the
main guy and i was the other guy
and that was kind of way out of my
league drunk dry and sober i ran that
place and i had to stop i was like i
can't be here why am i here
it was crazy town it really was crazy
maya p what do you miss most in least
about being a touring musician
energy of crowd
instant gratification instant response
they breathe we breathe
a bowl f
a bowl it's a ball if i messed it up
again a ball you can kick my ass hello
again mr shepherd you did me a solid by
doing a video from my wife that just
because i love her video my question is
what's a guilty pleasure of yours i.e a
song wardrobe or movie guilty pleasure
top gear
what's top gear british tv motoring
shows on for years jeremy clarkson you
loved it i still love it i was just
watching again recently there's so many
guilty pleasures yeah you know what boys
are back in town live from
from uh live and dangerous thing lizzy
that's a guilty pleasure
will f
leverage reboot do you see yourself
headed to nola
um
i wasn't invited for the first year
i love those guys they're really really
good and i dean devlin is the last
independent television studio
here yeah right and i love him and john
rogers who was part of the creation amy
berger created my character in that some
really great writers and great people
hell disarch for god's sake he's a
wonderful wonderful actor and christian
kane who we've intersected off and on
many many years lovely cooked he's a
great great chef really good chef nice
but he's just a sweet guy and i was
there to be one thing and then they did
the amazon thing and they sort of went
well i don't think he fits in what we're
doing so i took a bit of umbridge with
that
but you never know they've been picked
up for another one so right maybe
go ahead dean gets just blasted all day
with what about mark shepard when
sterling coming back does he
god stephen moffat said to me he said
would he please tell your fans that
i don't cast things the way
that they think i do
i write what i write and then when i've
written it i work out who i want to play
it right so why is 50 000 people saying
you need mark sheppard in sherlock or
you need money it's like
they don't understand a lot of those
writers don't understand that's not a
barrage then you do doctor who too
how many episodes i did uh two
episodes at the beginning of season six
do you still get people coming up to you
for doctor girls
it's wonderful it was in nixon's white
house during the uh space race really oh
god yeah and i'm playing a
uh
a former fbi agent
do you know i've never seen doctor who
it's fantastic i'll i'll tell you where
to start to what i mean which doctor do
i start with no well
the thing is what you grew up with is
your doctor right but me personally it's
not a bad place to start isn't it not to
go into monster of the week stuff but
but there is a really interesting arc
that starts with fish fingers and
custard you can do this for him
when matt smith starts at fish fingers
and custard goes through pandorica
through christmas
into the stuff i did in season six which
is written by neil gaiman written by
mark gadis written by some of the best
people so you watched a lot of episodes
no more than anything else i mean i
watched doctor who was a kid so they
kind of they came to me if it wasn't for
jim michaels supernatural i wouldn't
have been able to do it they flipped a
schedule around
in england so i could do it they offered
it to me and i was like of course and
they said when are you coming over to
the prosthetics as the older me that'll
make sense to you when you see it
um
and i said why don't you just ask my dad
that's right so he goes
would he do it of course he'd do it so i
call my dad and i go like you're doing
doctor who and he's like
didn't even ask him just said you're
doing doctor because is it all cardboard
and bits of string like it used to be
you know for sets i'm like no it's
fabulous and i sent him the same stuff
that i'm telling you about
and he and he watched matt smith he
would go this boy is incredible
beautiful actor
and he suddenly got that
thing of it of why it's so precious to
so many people wow so he played you
older he played the older me
what a genius thing and he had to do it
in utah so he had to get dispensation
from sag to do it as non-union oh my god
just telephone morgan here
i've got to do this thing but it's
non-union you want a waiver i don't know
do i want morgan you want a waiver you
want oh okay fine then i want a waiver
do you do you still get uh anxiety like
crippling anxiety or do you know how to
deal with it and what do you do for the
anxiety when you get what it's about
i've got kids
i've got kids i've got
22
16. with type one diabetes
and five nearly six six in a few days
yeah you know and i'm i'm wired badly
for that stuff
i get to panic i got to support them
i've got to do this i've got to do that
what if this what if that what if this
i'd drive myself up up the wall you know
luckily they've all got good therapists
do they have therapists
your kids have therapists
yeah i think everybody should be in
therapy that's good i got a 22 year old
who's smarter than i was at 30.
i got a 16 year old who's
smarter than all of us
and i got a five six almost six-year-old
daughter
who's just fantastic the five or
six-year-old daughter goes to therapy no
no
i was like wait a minute that would be
interesting the boys my boys are um
yeah they have their own thing you know
what though in this world
we didn't have that [ __ ] growing up that
they've got now no think of the idea of
dating at
16 or 20 years old it's it's like you
gotta have consent forms and
go take a trip to the go take a trip to
the doctor before you go on a date
it's craziness yeah
you know everything's on video all the
mess-ups and the stupid crap i did as a
kid if we'd have had camera phones i
don't know if i'd have made it to 20.
yeah i think that goes for everybody
yeah but it's like so it's so harsh out
there it is and they're smart kids you
know yeah i love having you on i love
you you know it's great because you just
you're one of those guests that you can
get deep but you also tell good stories
and it's easy to talk to you and i don't
have to sit there and
you i just sit back and enjoy yeah do
you feel like that it's just like all of
a sudden i'm in ireland i'm in belfast
now i'm on the [ __ ] city now i just
picture your dad and he's going to utah
to film this and i can it's just very
visual the truth of this is when we
discover when we go to
conventions or we go that's where we
usually will see each other and stuff
you know we're about out and about and
it's post show we're doing other things
but it's post the show that people are
seeing us for so our conversations
are not about the show we're on
we're all in the same boat we're all
part of that same thing right and we're
just trying to get a break and trying to
be kind and nice to the people who've
come to see us and try to elevate their
day and elevate their weekend and get
through
and then go home to our to our families
and and get on with the rest of our
lives having a hammering out a good
weekend
but we're all in the same boat there are
so many of us are in the same boat of a
certain
era and group and at any one given
moment any one of us could be
you know
the next
timothy dog well not tim tim's special
not tim i got an
eight-foot poster of tim in my dining
room
do you really from an italian
gladiator timothy dalton he's in a
centurion's uniform you know timothy
dalton knows yeah james bond okay yes of
course you know that yeah
yeah who's your favorite james bond he's
actually the second most popular james
bond in england you know who my first my
favorite is sean no oh god what's wrong
with you roger moore that's what i grew
up with no
i love roger moore morin jaws and uh
the guy who played jaws uh richard keel
mm-hmm but she kills it i love richard
kill i met him yeah richard kale in in
uh twilight twilight zone the book don't
get in the ship
it's a cookbook
how to cook man or whatever to serve
to serve man well hey thank you for
being here thank you for allowing me
inside of you will you come back again
anytime we have to we'll have to pick a
different subject maybe i'll interview
you next time
you know that's anyone there interviewed
you yet my brother did a long time ago
but you know he only wants to do it as
zach levi he wants to interview me so i
could be really good at that i'd
actually would i think that would be
brilliant oh my god
he'd go right after me too wouldn't he
he'd just be quick
we just disintegrate into long stories
but which is fine no no but he'd be
quick
he's such a small boy he is such a smart
he's a good guy i love him i think he's
a truly truly special person yeah i
think so too he's a wonderful guy so
it's time and tom's part it's the same
thing man it doesn't matter who's whose
turner is in the barrel right now you
know and sometimes we gotta wait a
little longer than everybody else
but
we're all happy when we're all okay does
that make sense
yeah we are all happy yeah when the next
thing it's like yeah okay that's good
i'm happy
yeah i agree you know that's the big i
think that's the biggest deal for any of
us is that this is a tough job made
tougher by circumstance right now
and we just grind our way through
and if you're lucky you end up like
tommy lee jones yeah exactly and try to
avoid the word
or hackman
you know what i like about mark what do
you like about mark you can talk he sure
can and that's saying in a good way it's
not like i have to pry [ __ ] out of them
take some pressure off of you doesn't it
certainly does there's nothing worse
than going oh so anyway and then like uh
twice
okay um so where are you from
brazil uh so um
did you like doing that movie
yeah
okay go [ __ ] girl
yeah i mean jeez louise thank you mark
thanks for being on the podcast tell us
what you think write to us we're on
instagram uh twitter uh youtube watch on
youtube subscribe uh subscribe
everywhere it's it's really helps when
you subscribe everywhere and you listen
wherever you can and we appreciate it
we're also on the uh the patreon if you
want to join patreon patreon by patrons
give back they help to keep the podcast
alive go to patreon.com inside of you
um i'll also be in st louis for fan expo
um may 13th weekend liverpool may 21st
illinois metropolis illinois june 10th
we're doing some marvel nights with tom
willing it's a two-man show it's gonna
be great
um a lot of fun stuff going on and a lot
of cool things to tell you
here in the future if you keep listening
there's some really exciting news coming
up that i'll tell you about but i just
want to thank you for listening today's
today's episode
um and now i'm going to read the top
tiers do we need to do anything else
no they know where to go
well
tell them
you go to i decided you pot on twitter
not inside of your podcast instagram and
facebook and you can follow the damn
thing that's what you can do that's what
you can do so if you enjoyed it today
uh i would also ask you guys if you
really love the podcast spread the word
force your family in a nice way
to listen to the podcast to subscribe to
the podcast to spread the word
and uh because we'd like you we'd like
to be one of your choices when it comes
to podcasts uh here we go these are the
top tier uh patrons
nancy d leah s sarah v little lisa
yukiko jill e brian h nico p i'm gonna
keep reading and i'm gonna do and you
say angry and then you or you could just
say different emotions different
emotions right so here i go all right
i'm gonna start out with just nancy d
leah s sarah v little lisa angry yukiko
jill e
brian h sad
nico p
robert b
jason w kristen k allison l ross
c
i sound like a sorority boys guy
really yeah dina why do you let them
treat you like this
elated
joshua d
cjp jennifer and stacy l jen asked jamal
f janelle b kimberly e mike he yelled on
sopremo quizzical
99 more
santiago m
chad w leon p janine r maya pete like
tom cruise
maddie s
belinda n chris h dave h spider-man
chase sheila g brad d ray h nicholson
ray h tabitha t tom and liliana a talia
m betsy d
chad l
rochelle
marion meg k trammell dan and big stevie
w
angel m rhiannon c give me another one
buffalo bill
cory k super sam dev nixon
michelle a jeremy c andy t
coney r gavinator
david c gary oldman
john b
brandy d
yvore
camille s
the c
joey m
willie f
david h
adelite n
omri
i'm trying to think of one lena n design
otg eugene and leah chris p nikki g
corey
heather l
jake
no what is that it's like the count
jake b
james b
able f joshua b i don't know what i'm
doing walking
tony g
sean r
megan t mel s orlando c
john b carolina
darren b robbie paul c christine s
sarah s eric h tom welling
spring
jennifer r i i have no idea that's a
tough one to do tom welling
um all right but guys uh thank you
all my lovely patrons who make this
possible and thank you jason nelkin my
wonderful editor thanks to ryan my
wonderful engineer and my cohort thanks
to westwood one cumulus for supporting
the podcast uh
and uh
thank you from myself michael roosev i'm
here in the hollywood hills of
california
and ryan taylor is also here in the
hollywood good morning
we love you guys be good to yourself be
good to others have a great week thanks
for choosing this podcast look not every
one of them is going to be a slam dunk i
thought today's was a slam dunk but you
know stay with us we're trying to give
you good good stuff here and we love you
and uh
keep us around all right
we'll talk to you talk we'll talk to you
[Music]